this is sewage from 1.4 million
residents in the Bay Area it might seem
like just waste but it's a gold mine for
researchers I am a Scientist and I'm
supposed to be skeptical and I continue
to be amazed that what we measure in
Wastewater seems to be so helpful sewage
has become a valuable tool that can help
officials tackle outbreaks like covid-19
monkey pox and even polio before people
show up at testing centers and hospitals
after officials found poliovirus in New
York sewage it became a state emergency
like the Wastewater epogee and we all
just like to say you know everybody uses
a toilet so how exactly do researchers
find viruses in our waste and what can
sewage tell us about public health
something
before researchers can find pathogens in
the sewage you have to flush it down
sewage from over a million Bay Area
residents ends up here at the San Jose
Santa Clara Regional Wastewater facility
this is everything that comes down the
drain when you take a shower brush your
teeth use the toilet all of your
excretions go into Wastewater and end up
at a wastewater treatment plant in 2020
researchers started the sewer
coronavirus alert Network also known as
scan at Stanford University the San Jose
facility works with scan 12 times a day
workers here collect samples of raw
sewage they sample the Wastewater after
the solids have settled out of it that's
now what's called sludge measurement is
250 milliliters the combined sample is
stored in this mini fridge until it's
full and collected once a day
then it's sent to verily a health
research company in South San Francisco
that partners with scan to test samples
from across the country here researchers
process samples for more than 60 plants
on a busy day they can test close to 70
samples after they arrive the liquid
needs to be separated from the solid
waste the samples are dropped into the
centrifuge and spun at tens of thousands
of revolutions per minute the solids
have about 100 times more viral
particles on a per Mass basis than the
liquid so we want to be able to detect
things that are at very low
concentrations or very rare in the sewer
shed are in the waste and so the solid
gives us the best opportunity to do that
after the solid settles at the bottom of
the tube the liquid is pulled out with a
pipette the lab only needs 0.5 grams to
test for viruses like covid-19 the rest
of the sample is saved in a negative 79
degrees Celsius freezer we want to
Archive that and save it if we ever need
to go back to test it for any new virus
that might have been circulating there
during that time or something we didn't
know about what happens is that the lab
staff take that solid and they as they
affectionately term it to roll it into a
poopsicle so that it can fit in a much
smaller tube than that large tube to
test for viruses the viral particles
need to be pushed into a liquid
preservative by force
after another round in the centrifuge
the viral DNA and RNA are ready to be
isolated verily it uses machines like
these to transfer samples and isolate
genetic material to make the process
more efficient
finally the samples are ready to be
tested verily uses PCR to figure out
just how much viral DNA and RNA is in
the sample PCR is a test used to detect
genetic material
the lab can test for up to three viruses
at a time using one plate each plate has
96 Wells for samples if the PCR detects
a specific virus it makes millions of
copies of the genetic material and tags
them a fluorescent color that
information is plotted on this graph
where researchers can see just how much
of each virus was in the sample that day
so these are ones these gray ones here
these are ones that had no virus no
viral RNA or DNA in that particular well
these are ones that had monkey pox
SARS cov2 and human meta pneumovirus so
just looking at this you can see
there's more SARS cov2 than there is
monkey pox and there's probably a little
bit more human metanuma virus than there
is monkey pox the whole testing process
takes eight hours that's longer than it
takes to test a covet swap sample but
sewage is a lot more complicated
researchers still consider Wastewater to
be what's called a leading indicator
people can shed the virus into
Wastewater before they even show
symptoms and know to get tested this
past winter in Boston specifically you
saw the Wastewater level Spike before we
really saw the Omicron variant take off
and so that sometimes gives Public
Health officials in hospitals a heads up
saying okay something might be coming
here we should probably prepare and
researchers say it's efficient one
Wastewater sample from the San Jose
facility covers over a million people
not everybody has a primary care
provider or when they feel sick has the
ability or even wants to go out and get
tested it is a really sort of unbiased
broad way of sort of collecting
Community samples which is helpful for
public health now officials across the
country monitor Wastewater for covid
since the pandemic started there has
been a huge surge in interest in using
Wastewater to monitor Community Health
but it's not a perfect tracking system
sewage can't pinpoint who exactly is
sick and it can't provide a total case
count either instead it provides
information on the level of virus in the
community and how it changes over time
the idea of testing Wastewater isn't new
it's a pretty old technology actually
it's decades old and primarily it was
used to sort of monitor for polio and in
New York that old technology helped
alert officials to the recent spread of
poliovirus throughout the state Governor
Kathy hokel declared polio a state
disaster in September
scan and verily are also testing for
diseases like monkey pox and influenza A
once you have that infrastructure in
place there's an economy of scale like
you can easily swap in and swap out
assays like we were able to do with
monkey pox tracking diseases isn't the
only thing Wastewater surveillance can
be used for cities like Cary North
Carolina and Tempe Arizona have been
tracking opioid usage through Wastewater
even before the pandemic an
epidemiologists are exploring how
hospitals can use their own Wastewater
to test for antibiotic resistant
bacteria but Bain hopes Wastewater
surveillance could be useful Beyond labs
and public health officials a dream
could be that we know it's like a
weather report like you know in your
community what is circulating we do have
this vision for all the uses of
Wastewater and it includes things like
pandemic response Staffing at Hospitals
and Clinics choice of pharmaceuticals or
non-pharmaceutical interventions and
even vaccine development
foreign